these are magnetic microrobots just
millimeters in size they Bend and move
in response to applied magnetic fields
and with these magnetic fields
controlled by a gaming controller the
micro robots can be driven carefully and
precisely they can turn by changing the
direction of the magnetic field role in
a rotating field an even grasp and jump
it often feels like you're playing a
video game in some previous work I did
as a demonstration I was pushing blocks
of material around and using a micro BA
like a bulldozer and the demonstration I
did was playing Tetris
the idea is this technique could be used
to assemble human organ tissues by
arranging blocks of different types of
cells in particular patterns the way
these scientists actually fabricate the
micro robots is pretty ingenious tiny
rare earth magnets are magnetized in a
strong magnetic field then they're mixed
into a UV resin that will harden when
exposed to UV light the mixture is
poured into a mold and placed on a stage
below which is a rotatable permanent
magnet this creates an adjustable
magnetic field to which all the tiny
magnets in the resin align when the
desired orientation is reached UV light
cures the resin in one particular spot
locking those magnets in place then the
magnetic field can be adjusted and the
next section cured ultimately the result
is a flexible device with imbedded
magnets that have different orientations
depending on where they are this pattern
of orientations is what gives these
micro robots their unique behavior in
response to magnetic fields in opposite
directions within a flexible device if
we apply the field vertically those
compass needles will both try to orient
aligned with the right magnetic fields
the results can be pretty sophisticated
watch this micro robot pick up a block
and then roll with it over to a ramp it
rolls up the ramp deposits the block at
the top and then returns to its original
position the idea is that devices like
this could be used in medical
applications so this could be sending a
device into fluid areas in your body or
into your gastrointestinal tract for
example a capsule that you could swallow
which will go passively through your GI
tract have no wires attached and at the
right moment we can activate a sampling
chamber basically to open up and take
samples of either stomach or small
intestine contents take biopsy samples
of the intestinal wall but grippers like
these may not be the only magnetic
microrobots invading your body a
different research group has
these even smaller peanut-shaped
magnetic particles and under the right
magnetic field conditions they form
swarms this warm can take on different
configurations the vortex where many
particles travel together like a school
of fish the chain where particles line
up and travel single-file and the ribbon
where motion is perpendicular to the
line of particles one potential
application of micro robotic swarms is
drug delivery each magnetic particle
could carry a small amount of drug and
be guided toward the intended drug
delivery site so to make a swarm useful
for central biomedical application you'd
like to keep the swarm aggregated you
probably will not be able to see single
micrometer sized particles but you could
see the entire swarm so you'd like to
keep it aggregated so you can move it
and keep track but then going through
tight environments for example going
through blood vessels if your swarm the
overall swarm size is bigger than the
blood vessel then it doesn't fit so you
need to line them up and squeeze through
so that's the motivation for being able
to control the shape of the swarm and
who knows one day you might have swarms
of magnetic microrobots cleaning your
teeth
another group of researchers has used
tiny magnetic robots to clear biofilms
those are communities of bacteria and
the protective sugar polymers around
them they typically build up on medical
devices the insides of pipes and on
teeth
can I ask does this idea of magnetic
control of micro robots does it supplant
previous concepts like I'm trying to
conceptualize this in terms of like you
know sci-fi futures with nanobots where
I imagine you know we imagine these
things is really self-contained and you
know powering themselves around the body
and that sort of stuff yeah
great question so the advantage of
magnetic fields is that it's a very
scalable technique so we can make
magnetic microbots that are single cell
size and we can make them that are
centimeters in size and the principles
behave similarly it pulls off a lot of
the functionality to
or magnetic coils we can have a big
computer sitting there and power supply
it's a lot of the hard aspects of
dragging a robot we can do as
traditional size okay I'm a big computer
we can have medical imaging hooked up
and do all these things off board and
then on board we're just transmitting
the magnetic field directly to the
device and so this our Mike robot is
basically then just like the mechanical
hand of the robot and the rest of the
robot is really sitting on the table
beside the patient hey this episode of
veritasium is supported by viewers like
you on patreon and by audible there's no
better place to listen listening makes
us smarter more connected people and
there's no better time to start
listening than right now with a 30-day
trial and your first audiobook plus two
audible originals free when you go to
audible.com slash veritasium or text
veritasium that's BER I TAS I um - 500
500 now if you're looking for something
good to listen to might I recommend how
to change your mind with the new science
of psychedelics teaches us about
consciousness dyeing addiction
depression and transcendence by Michael
Pollan this is a fascinating book and
it's narrated by the author himself I'm
actually listening to it at the moment
and he may be changing my mind about the
very nature of consciousness what I find
so incredible is how recent this
scientific field is and what it's
revealing about how all of our brains
work now when I'm listening to books
like this I actually look forward to
getting stuck in traffic
I find it reduces my stress levels
because I'm learning something rather
than just wasting time in the car now
the way it works with audible is that as
a member you can choose three titles
each month one audiobook and two audible
originals that you can't hear anywhere
else and if you don't like a book you
can exchange it no questions asked and
the books you get are yours to keep you
can go back and re-listen anytime even
if you cancel your membership just go to
AUD ible comm slash veritasium or text
veritasium to five hundred five hundred
and browse their unmatched selection of
audio content so I want to thank audible
for supporting me and I want to thank
you for watching